[Music]
this is bear son it was the home of your
grandparents and their grandparents
before that but out there beyond the
edge of the warranty why is the home of
the Dragons
and I believe this your destiny to one
day find this hidden world
[Music]
you do know my leg isn't a chew toy
don't you is this what you want yeah go
get
how am I supposed to get down hey buddy
wait up he's not the only one
[Music]
another night she's more like a right
all night Gary
yeah yours is better probably there is
an armada with enough cages for all of
our track insane
this is a new kind of enemy we need to
find the hidden world I will destroy
everything you realize
you're nothing without your blanket if
criminal succeeds there won't be any
Dragons left and it's up to us to put an
end to it
so what are you gonna do about it suit
up game we have one shot you brought a
baby to a battle - iterator
and I hit it morals have really touched
the key
right but inside
well what Kunis not a word
[Music]